oh my god no no
how do we get up oh i forgot to stop
this is gonna be harder than i thought
hi my name's tucker and i'm gonna learn
how to roller skate i am
kind of just a clumsy all-around person
i've always been the
skinny lanky kid i thought i'd challenge
myself
to be able to do something i'm not good
at
no no and show my family and friends
and any stranger in the park that's
looking what i accomplished in
seven days step one we need to acquire
some roller skates
boom i borrowed them from a friend so
honestly thankful they're a little
scuffed up because
they're about to get a little more
scuffed up if you know what i mean i
haven't looked at a pair of skates in
years i opened a wikihow article that
explained how to roller skate walk like
a duck
step three is walk like a duck okay i
don't know how much i trust this
i learn by doing so i was just like
screw this
i'm just gonna freaking learn this on my
own let's see
no okay maybe i should go back to the
article
okay here we go here we go how do you
stop oh my god it's on the front
i wanted to skate in the garage just
because it was the flattest ground i
could see
and then i saw the ramp and i realized
if i could conquer that ramp
i could do anything that'd be good
[Music]
fully fell on my ass and i still have a
bruise actually
okay can we just look at this i'm
sopping wet
oh my gosh it's been maybe like 15
minutes
this is gonna be harder than i thought
tony bravo
is another talent resident here at
buzzfeed with me
a fantastic roller skater the epitome of
beauty and grace so i thought why not
learn from the best
hi i'm tony i've been skating since i
was
pretty young i started off skate park
skating
and now i've been doing a lot more
groove skating flat ground skating and
stuff like that stop
she's just such a warm presence even
though my abilities were
quite limited she was just so
encouraging there you go
there you go there you go
i see you brought absolutely no
protective gear with you talking about
an ounce
that is a no-no first day i really
wanted tucker to get comfortable
using his toe stops because learning how
to stop is
very important and bring that
there you go i mean let's just try to
move forward
lean your body out push your up
not quite like that okay let's try a
different one let's try a different one
he did
really well on the first day i was
so shocked keep those knees bent there
you go
he was not holding back at all uh which
made it very exciting
so i definitely got to my car that day i
was a little discouraged
i really hope that i improve
oh it was a big reality check damn
you're gonna have to put in some work
this week
um okay can the final performance just
be me going straight
honestly i'm on a rampage so day two was
a solo
journey for me i realized hey i have an
agenda today i have to master
the standing up on two legs
the going forward
and the braking
did i do it no but i tried
how do i get up look at that toe stopper
hold on let me come closer i have like
burnt rubber okay maybe i'll go down
half of this no i won't no i won't no i
won't
no i won't no okay day two has
adjourned i am exhausted i'm very sweaty
but i am getting more confident
and i'm proud of myself so day three i
was really excited to show
tony my new ability but tony had the
brilliant idea of taking me to a skate
park
instead okay i'm ready
you have things that's not the correct
helmet
or uh what is this equipment that's a
bike helmet the second day
at the skate park we got a little bit
more comfortable with
learning how to skate on an incline
stage your legs
and just follow that momentum toe stop
there you go
a little toe really dig in
stagger it's hunger
it takes people so long to learn how to
pivot and you're just doing it
i i think it's more me falling over but
so tony sat me down
and told me that my roller skates were
uh i knew in my mind without a doubt we
needed it to
head over to pigeons and get him some
upgrades
[Music]
pigeon skate shop one of my favorite
spots
we went in to go get tucker some
protective gear
and some actually good skates
am i in an art gallery or a skate shop
this is so beautiful honestly
for you we're looking at something
like this they look so good on you
you already look like such a better
skater okay wow
shake your head a little bit yeah that
one that one's not your size we're gonna
need a size down
i'm dead if i wear this i'm dead i mean
this one i hit a car
the car's dead so i got a black helmet
to match the black skates and the black
pads
i'm kind of mixing things up this is a
new skate new me
hello first of all thank you for having
us you're welcome
i'm so excited for you to skate in some
really good skates
perfect are you kidding me i was
completely elated when i got the gear
i felt like now i could tackle the
garage ramp
without fear of losing my life okay so
outfit check
yeah yeah and here we go
[Music]
i did the freaking garage ramp it wasn't
graceful
but check mark wow i'm on slop of the
world again
okay skate around i'm feeling good
except
tomorrow because i'm starting to learn
like the actual routine now i am a
little scared because that brings a
whole set of new challenges
okay it's day five i just got to the
park
and obviously as soon as i started
driving here it starts raining
very hard in la what
so today i want to get you a little more
comfortable with some fancy stuff we'll
practice a couple spins
so tony taught me the spins which i
felt good about i mean we are spinning
in unison we're spinning together
and i didn't fall it was a wonderful
time
uh unfortunately the hill was another
story
right now we're about halfway up here
there's a small child that i'm about to
absolutely destroy right now
just kidding okay guess we're going
oh my god
oh my god i'm totally good thank you i
mean if i got it on the first try that's
not fun
i fell that's not what we want for the
final performance
should we take five or maybe like five
days
when i saw tucker fall and he looked a
bit discouraged
i knew it was time for just a little a
little pep talk
how are you feeling i'm fine i am just
kind of concerned because that was
halfway
right up the hill and it didn't go as
planned
right i i could totally understand you
feeling a bit discouraged yeah you need
to cut yourself some slack though you're
dealing with some wet terrain it just
rained
true thank you it was the pep talk that
i needed because
it instantly got me back up on my feet
to do another attempt
bend your knees put stick that butt out
unfortunately that attempt also did not
go as planned but
oh i forgot to stop
okay and so routine wise so you're gonna
come down the hill you're gonna come to
a stop using your toe stop and we'll do
a couple of nice little spins at the end
there okay
yeah i think you got this though i'm
like
fairly confident in you fairly fairly
so after the low point of day five i
knew that on day six i had to get my
confidence back
up or this final performance was not
going to be good
did it oh he did it yeah can we
truly cut back right now to me going
down that freaking hill
the first time
guys sorry i am screaming in public
right now but i am so impressed with
myself i did a freaking lap around my
neighborhood
and i didn't fall i'm going into
tomorrow feeling confident
feeling excited and more than anything
else i'm going in tomorrow
not feeling clumsy which is a true first
for me
day seven i'm waking up in the morning
and all i can think about
is the performance let's do this
there were people waiting for me when i
got to the park i could tell though
they did not have any confidence in me
[Music]
are you excited i'm super excited until
you have to go down the hill then i'm
scared
i told you i said she was going to be
scared that's why i shouldn't be here
oddly enough that didn't affect me i
knew
that i had been working towards this
goal and i
knew that i was going to accomplish it
if i could conquer this i could do
[Music]
[Music]
anything
it's hard to put into words how many
emotions i was feeling
beautiful
i was so so proud of tucker i knew he
had it in him from the beginning but it
was really great to
see him believe that he could do it as
well
weave them oh my gosh
tony is a miracle worker this experience
gave me the confidence i needed to pick
up new things that i'm scared to do
that i have previously not done out of
fear of embarrassing myself
put yourself out there try something new
because you know what this is
our life so stop caring about what other
people think about you
you clumsy person own it
[Music]
you